it is the cold hand of Nightfall that
opens the door to our deepest fears
for most it is only a creeping dread
scratching at the corner of our mind
but for one family in 1977's London
dread was just the beginning I'm
starting the anfield Poltergeist case
what you're seeing
is a reimagining of those events but
what you're about to hear
is real
what do you want tell us what you want
I can't comment you
as an 11 year old girl we experience the
original recordings it was like
someone's knocking to come in
in the chilly new docu-series people
witnessed Janet levitation
the Enfield Poltergeist streaming
October 27th on Apple TV Plus